öncelikle şunu belirteyim yapacağım
konuşmanın önemli dinleyicilerinden bir
tanesi de benim ömrümü boyunca
Yaşadıklarımdan çıkarımların olmasına
binaen anlatacaklarım ve Söyleyeceklerim
kendim için hatırlatıcı ve Telkin
niteliğindedir bugün karşınızda bir
basketbolcu değil de eski baskı kurucu
Tabiri caizse erken yaşta emekli olmuş
bir basketbolcu olarak soruyorum 35
yaşına kadar her türlü oynarım dediğin
basketbola 28 yaşında Yaşadığım bir
sakatlıktan dolayı veda ettim
basketbolda Bana Veda etmiş olabilir
orası pek mümkün
yaşadım Aslında bunların bunlara binaen
tedavisi gösterim oldu sakatlıktan
döndükten sonra kötü performans
gösterdiğim zamanlar oldu Ama eninde
sonunda ben yine o sahaya Çıkıp kendimi
göstermeye tekrar basketbol oynama
fırsatı buluyordum
2018 yılında bu böyle olmadı 2018
yılında Darüşşafaka Doğuş'un lisans
sporcuydum ve euro kampanyasında Çok
ciddi bir kadro kurmuştu o takımının
kaptanları sorumluluğu da bana
verilmişti Euro capa'nın ne olduğunu
bildiğimiz açısından söylüyorum Euro Cup
Avrupa düzeyinde kulüpler bazında en
büyük ikinci kupa dediğim gibi gayet
kimyasal oturmuş bir takımda başarılı
bir sezon geçiriyorduk başarılı bir
sezon geçiriyorduk ama bir önceki
sezonda benim sol Dizimde yavaş yavaş
küçük ağrılarım olmaya başlamıştı o
Sezon başında ağrılarım artmıştı ama ben
o ağrıları İğnelerle Ağrı kesiderlerle
tölere edebiliyordum Çünkü takımın
Kaptan olmanın bana vermiş olduğu bir
sorumluluk vardı ve onun dışında o
sezonun Euro kapı kazanacağımızın inancı
beni aynı şekilde hem motive ediyordum
sezon ortasına geldik ağrılarım iyice
arttı ve doktora gittik doktora artık
ameliyat olmam gerektiğini söyledi ve
planımız sezonun bittikten sonra
ameliyat olmak
2018 senesinde Euro kapı kazandık
o kupayı kaldırdım benim için çok
değerli ve Onu rezici bir sezondu onu da
bize bir sezondu ve her şey
planladığımız gibi gidiyordu Sezon
sonunda ameliyat olacaktım ki ameliyata
gayet aşinayım Çünkü o zamana kadar
birçok sakatlık geçirdim saymam
gerekirse alnım kırıldı burnum kırıldı
elim acıdı göğüs kafesim kırıldı ki bu
da bana söylemediler göğüs kafesinin
kırık olarak oynadım
bileğim çıktı ki o çok trajiktir en son
bileğimi gördüğümde o da bana böyle
bakıyordu Bunu size burada izletmek
isterdim ama o videoyu izleyince çok da
aynı fikirde tekrar devam etmedim Çünkü
en sonunda acıdan yerleri yerlere
yumrukluyordum en çok merak ediyorum
varsa YouTube'a girip videoyu
seyredebilir
dediğim gibi ilk defa ameliyat
olmuyordum bu zamana kadar bu
sakatlıklara binen 3 defa ameliyat
olmuştum ve bunun dışında farklı farklı
derler görmüştüm O ameliyatta bunlardan
biriydi benim ameliyatımı oldum ameliyat
bitti Doktorum bana söylediği 6-8 aylık
bir tedavi süreci var yani Biz aslında
öyle sanıyorduk Bugün 60 ayın
üzerindeyiz
arkadaş pek tedaviye cevap vermedi 20'li
yaşların başında o Gençliğim de verdiği
enerjiyle Beraber biraz kendisine biraz
fazla hor kullanmış olacağım ki 28
yaşında azerbay Yurttaş Hayır sen
basketbolcuda falan bırak yani oynama
demiyorum oyna ama hani Hobi olarak
oynar şeklinde bir yaklaşım gösterdi Ben
de bu aralar sadece arkadaşlarımla
beraber Hobi olarak oynayabiliyorum ki
oynadıktan sonra bizim balon balığı gibi
şişmeye başlıyor
Şimdi şöyle düşünün Ben 14 yaşında
hayatımda basketbol Odak noktasını almış
biriyim ve 28 yaşında Basketbolu
bırakmak zorunda kalacağım
doktorların bir yandan böyle deneme
tahtası haline gelmişim her doktor
farklı bir tedavi uyguluyor ve her
doktor farklı cümlelerle beni
motivasyonumu bozmaya başlıyor bunu bu
yüzden ben aynı zamanda psikolojik bir
savaş içerisinde Peki bu benim için
hayır mıydı Yani bunu bilemezsin değil
mi Ama yerimde oturup da bekleyemezdim
bunun için çaba sarf etmeliydim ama
bazen hayatınızda çaba sarf etmeden de
hatta aksiyon de çaba sarf ettikçe de o
Hayır sizin ayağınıza gelebiliyor bunun
örneklerinden bir tanesini Ben küçükken
yaşadım aslında şu an hamdolsun 2
metrenin üzerinde olan boyun küçükken de
akranlarımın arasında hep uzundu
şu an hamdolsun diyorum ama dilim bir de
siz onu ilkokul çağlarındaki Furkan'a
sorun
arkadaşlarımın acımasız lakaplarına
maruz kalıyordum sınıfta her seferinde
enerji atılıyordum İstiklal Marşı'nı en
arkadan okuyordum herkese görüyordum
ondan sorun yok istediğim kıyafetleri
bulamıyordum ayakkabıcıya gidiyoruz
ailemin Hani nasıl bir mantığı var
bilmiyorum ama şu şekilde
yaklaşıyorlardı ya Hanım bu çocuğun
ayakkabılar falan ayaklar fazla büyüyor
biz bunları biraz küçük ayaklar alalım
ondan sonra bunu ayaklarımın büyümesi
durursun yani tıbbi olarak bir karşılığı
var mı bilmiyorum ama mantıyı çözemedim
Hani ayak Tamam durdurdun onu da Boyun
ne yapacağız yani 40 numara ayak 28 boy
mu hani burada bir oran orantı var
Rabbim en güzel şekilde yaratmış Yani
bunu niye bozmaya uğraşıyorsunuz
buna benzerse hayatlardan ben uzun
boyumdan çok daha memnun değilim Hatta
küçüklük yaşamın verdiği o artık nasıl
bir düşünceye yakışırsa boyun kısalsın
diye farklı farklı şeyler uyguluyordum
Bunları anlatıp size böyle saçma
hikayeleri anlatıp baktığınızı çalmak
istemiyorum en basitini söyleyeceğim
hepinizin evinde önceden bir eliptik
aleti vardır annelerimiz alır ama asla
kullanmaz İşte ben o alete binip üstüne
çıkarak o zaman boyun kısalt azan boyum
kısalt diye yalvarıyordum ama bu boyumun
benim için hayatımda ve ömrümde gurur
duyacağım bir meslek haline geleceğini
bilmiyordum
bilemezdim de o yüzden
burada benim şer olarak gördüğümün
hayıra döneceğini bilmiyordum Peki her
seferinde bu şer dediğimiz şey bizim
ayağımıza bu şekilde mi gelecekti
2018'de benim için böyle olmadı ben
yerimde oturup hayatımda bazı şeylerin
güzelleşmesini bekleyemezdim bir çaba
sarf etmeliydim uğraş göstermeliydim
zihnimi ve kalbimi diri tutup bunun için
bir şeyler yapmalıydım Aslında işin
psikolojik yanı Çok önemli çünkü bu
durumda çok ağır bir hayal kırıklığı
yaşıyorsunuz ki ben öyle Yaşadım ve
hayal kırıklığı bir yerden sonra sizin
zihninizi kemirmeye başlıyor Peki bundan
nasıl sığdırabiliriz küçük bir kısa
anlatacağım aranızda bilenler vardır Ben
buradan çıkarım yaptım zamanında
Ticaretle de uğraşan imamlardan Ebu
Hanifi Hazretleri talep edilirken
dışarıdan bir adam geliyor diyor ki ya
imam gemilerin batmış İmamı Azam şöyle
küçük bir düşünüp Elhamdülillah diyor ve
dersine devam ediyor Daha sonra aynı
adam tekrardan geliyor ve bu sefer diyor
ki yaymam yanlış duymuşuz Vatan gemiler
senin değilmiş İmam Azam'ın cevap cevabı
aynı oluyor Elhamdülillah tabi
talebeleri bu duruma şahit olunca merak
ediyorlar Bu işin Sırrı hikmeti nedir
soruyorlar ya hocam diyorlar Hani önce
size gemilerinizin battığı Haberi geldi
daha sonra batan gemilerin sizin olm
adığını yine Elhamdülillah
şöyle kalbime bir baktım içimde kalbimde
dünyada bir şey kaybetmekten dolayı
herhangi bir hüzün var mı olmadığını
gördüm ve Elhamdülillah dedim Daha sonra
batan gemilerin benim olmadığını
öğrenince tekrardan kalbime baktım
dünyalık bir şey kazanmak Bundan
kazanmaktan dolayı bir mutluluk yaşıyor
muydum Hayır bu yüzden yine
Elhamdülillah dedim Rabbime kalbime
dünyalık bir sevgi koymadığı için
şükrediyor şimdi buradan ne
çıkarabiliriz öncelikle şunu söyleyeyim
yani aramızda evliya Yoksa bu şekilde
Feraceler gösterebilecek biri maalesef
aramızda yok hani biz bunu yapamayız Ama
ne yapabiliriz örnek alabiliriz
benim kendi çıkarım buradan şu oldu
hayatımızda birçok olumlu ve olumsuz
şeyler olacak ve bunların karşısında
bizim güzellikler karşısında gereğinden
fazla şımarmayarak veya olumsuzluklar
karşısında gereğinden fazla hayal
kırıklığı yaşamadan kendimizi depresyon
haline sokmamamız lazım Ben bunu yaşadım
ben boşluğa düştüm Çünkü benim hayatım
basketbol bu ve ben basketbolun içinde
kendimi motive ediyordum taraftarın bana
bağırması ki aslan burcunun böyle ölmeyi
sevdiğini söylerler Ben Aslan burcuyum
Ben onlarla enerji buluyordum ve o
Sağdaki adrenalin beni motive ediyordu
Ben bunları artık kaybediyordum bu beni
boşluğa bırakmıştı ama biz burada bir
çaba göstermedik Benim düştüğüm yerden
kalkmasını bilmem lazımdı hayatımızda
her seferinde bir şeyleri başkasının
yapmasını bekleyemeyiz veya çaba sarf
etmeden bir şeylerin güzelleşmesini
bekleyemeyiz Çünkü ne olursa olsun
olumlu veya olumsuz
hemen diğerine başlamanız lazım
başlamazsanız oraya davet hale veya O
hayal kırıklığı geçirdiğiniz boş
vakitlerin süresini arttırıyor ve boş
vakitler size tembellik getiriyor o
tembellik sizi daha kötü bir insan
haline götürüyor O yüzden oradan çok
hızlı bir şekilde sıyrılmalıyız o
sıyrılmayı da yerimizde bekleyerek değil
gayret ederek yapmalıyız Çünkü insana
çalıştığı kadarı vardır
Peki male yani ve boş vakit temizken
bunun sebeplerinden bir tanesi de yine
kendime çıkarımındadır erteleme
hastalığımız bu erteleme hastalığımız
Neden olur ve bunu nasıl yenebiliriz
Bence yine Benim kendime çıkarımdır önce
bir farkındalık oluşturmamız lazım benim
üzerine yoğunlaştığım 3 tane şey var
Birincisi mükemmeliyetçilik ki kimse
sizden mükemmel bir iş beklemiyor
ikincisi Bunu daha çok bilinçaltınız
yapıyor insanların Sizin yaptığınız
gerektiği şeyleri insanların yapmasını
bekliyorsunuz onlardan beklediğiniz için
kendinize geri çekiyorsunuz üçüncüsü de
Konfor alanınızdan çıkamamak Aslında
ikincisiyle üçüncüsü birbiriyle
bağdaşıyor babam Allah onlar razı olsun
Kariyerim boyunca birçok ismi kendisi
gördü 14 yaşında başlayan basketbol
hayatında antrenmanlarıma gelmesi
götürdü maçları kendisi götürdü benim o
yaşta bile üzerime düşen
sorumluluklarımı babam gördü Hatta
basketbolda o kadar ilgiliydi ki artık
Bundan sonraki hayatına baskı balığın
içine devam ettirecek diye
düşünebilirdiniz lakin benim Basketbolu
bırakmamla beraber basketbolda bıraktı
sanırım onun daha çok böyle mutlu eden
ve Basketbolu sevdiren benim o sahada
onlanmış şu an kendisi Balıkesir'de
Çiftlik ayarı yaşıyor burada babama
suçlamıyorum Çünkü babam bunu gayet iyi
niyetle sadece evladığımı korumak onun
Konfor alanının geliştirmek istiyordu
bunu Aslında birçok ebeveyn yapıyor ama
Ebeveynler bunu aşırıya kaçırınca Bu
sefer o çocuklar zarar görmeye başlıyor
ama hayatımızda her şeyi hiçbir uğraş
göstermeden veya başkalarının yaparak
düzelmesini beklemeli beklememeyiz
düştüğümüz yerden kalkmasını bilmeliyiz
ve önemlilerden bir tanesi de yerden
kalkarken kimin desteğini kimin eline
uzanabileceğimizi bilmemiz lazım bu
konuda birazcık arkadaş tarafına gelmek
istiyorum çünkü arkadaş tabiri çok
farklı bir tabir Bence arkadaş farklıdır
dost farklıdır bugün Etrafınıza bakın
Bugün aslında bir tabir vardı zamanında
biliyorsunuz kötü gün dostu diye şu an
kötü gün dostu bulmak çok kolay kötü
gününüzde insanlar genelde size ararlar
işte bir işte ihtiyacınız var mı diye
sorarlar herhangi bir şekilde işte size
nasıl yardımcı olabiliriz diye sorarlar
Ama iyi gün dostu kaç tane arkadaşımız
var Bundan kastım şu; Gerçekten sizin
başarınızla veya mutluluğunuzla sevinen
kaç tane arkadaşınız var bir tabir var
insanlar arkadaşlığının iyi olmasını
isterler ama kendilerinden iyi değil
aynı Platformu paylaşıyorsanız orada
birazcık hasret ve kıskançlık girdiği
için işte oradan çıkamıyorsunuz ve o
arkadaş bir yerden sonra güzel
günlerinizle size samimi bir şekilde
destek ol
Peki şunu sorabilirsiniz ya Furkan sen
bize bunları anlatıyorsun da sen 2018'de
bir sakatlık geçirmişsin Hani Bundan
sonra bu sakatlığı nasıl hayra
yoruyorsun Ben basketbol hayatım boyunca
kendi hedeflerimle kariyer planım 35
yaşına kadar basketbolumu oynar 35
yaşında maske açar kahvemi içer keyfime
bakarımdır bu çok bencilce bir hayaldi
ve ben bunun farkına sakatlığından sonra
vardım çünkü sakatlığından sonra
Yaşadıklarım benim geçirdiğim Bu
kariyerimin benim için bir nimet
olduğunu gördüm ve Bunu kullanmam
gerektiğini gördüm Yeni hayaller kurdum
Ben etrafımda Elhamdülillah eşimin
ailemin arkadaşlarının dostlarımın
hepsinin desteğini samimi bir şekilde
hissediyorum onların desteğini Nimet
Biliyorum ve aklıma senin şükrediyorum
şimdi kendime yeni hayaller kurdum ama
Hayallerim olmazsa olmazlarım değilim bu
sefer kalbimi o hayallerimi endeks
istemiyorum Çünkü yine başarısız
olabilir bu çıktığım yolda yine
istediğim gibi gitmeyebilir yine
planlarıma uymayabilir
ama ben kalbimi buna hazırlıklı tutmaya
çalışıyorum basketbolun içinde bildiğim
yerde kendime yeni bir yol haritası
çizdim bu yol haritasında kendime
Dostlarımı arkadaşlarımı yanıma alacağım
insanlara dikkatli seçtiğim ve onların
desteğiyle beraber yoluma bakmaya
çalışıyorum
zahiren bizim şer olarak gördüklerimiz
hayır olabilir ama bunun için gayret
etmeliyiz bunun için çaba sarf etmeliyiz
düştüğümüz yerden kalkmalıyız Ben böyle
yapmaya çalışıyorum ve gayret ediyorum
unutmayın Kader gayrete aşıktır
sabrınız ve dinlediğiniz için teşekkür
ederim